i thought you could talk to me
[Music]
parody week you can find today's track
and all of our greatest hits from over
the years by subscribing to the podcast
on spotify apple android and all other
major platforms before they ban us has
your husband ever made a stock purchase
or sale based on the produce
no
absolutely not
okay
[Music]
but somehow she still believes that none
of us will notice
[Music]
use of chemical weapons
[Music]
without the talent she's caught
[Music]
see
[Applause]
first clash of flight for free
she's high society
she's got the best of everything
so they know that we can't but it's the
s from taxpayers just like me
but willing supporters
she's brittle as she can be
hope no one ever drops her nose
[Music]
society
[Music]
what i like older women
with large
slightly floppy breasts
yeah me too
[Music]
did you even know about that trip
she comes to speak to me
slurring words on the tv
cause what she said sounds so [ __ ]
patrick's name is now so
cause somehow she's already
at least 14
always good drinks know where she
belongs the betty ford clinic
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
lovely uh that's a great intro for
senator marco rubio
[Laughter]
he's gonna be on the show today yeah who
knows which directions that's you know i
mostly like the guy
mostly i like what he did with the cigar
the cigar builds cigar whatever it is
researchers get that i should know that
the cigar belt clinton yes
that's called the sexual harassment bill
yes well the walking murdered a guy
um okay
it's thursday it's been a long week i
you know this is a pet peeve of mine you
can
comment below when people say oh i
didn't someone who suffers from insomnia
when people say oh i didn't sleep last
night no what you mean is you didn't
sleep well you didn't sleep a lot i
never went to sleep
at all not at all
no
wow it's kind of fun
this ought to be a good show yeah
so you'll feel free to admonish me and
by the way this has been parody week all
of them are available if you subscribe
to the audio podcast on spotify apple
android really helps the show out you
now have them for free all of our
previous parody tracks there's like 20
something there you can download them
take them with you to go you guys asked
hopefully we delivered and i just ask
that you leave a rating uh review
subscribe you have to subscribe though i
think to download them so all right we
have a lot to talk about today aoc is a
lying sociopath uh obviously there was a
tragic shooting in memphis the good news
is the man is in custody we'll talk
about that and we also have um
a segment that we introduced a while ago
but we sort of had to sit on it the make
my professor famous segment and you can
send your hidden uh your hidden camera
or audio recording of what's going on in
your it actually doesn't
should be university actually i guess
it happens everywhere but university
it's at what teacher tips at
lighterwithcrowder.com you can send them
in we have a professor from i believe
it's uni university of north
texas is it unt yeah they all sort of
bleed together they do as communist crap
holes so we have that today uh a man
teaching students uh pro censorship
views pro
lgbtq2saaip number two and also checking
your whiteness the guy's a racist put it
that way the guy is a racist communist
and uh you know if you think that that's
a mislabeling uh come at me bro uh all
right
gerald a how are you sir better than you
and i have kids that still don't sleep
through the night i got more sleep than
you even with that really they don't
sleep for the night well you have the
one the little one a little one four
month old that crossover when they sleep
a full night oh you think first off it's
like did something did they die right
you're like oh thank god i was this
close to shaking him
[Applause]
and then you're like no they're fine
they actually just slept the night oh
speaking of shake weights uh the fastest
man on his feet the quickest wit in the
west i am on tour with him this fall
fall spring fall i keep meaning to say
spring because we're doing a spring tour
we haven't announced it yet you can go
to lightweight.com
tour uh phoenix a few seats just opened
up we opened some yeah like about a
hundred seats just so you know but
houston september 17th at the smart
financial center dave landa how are you
ahoy good i slept fine the good for you
the dreams were still there yeah
pelosi dreams the terrors yeah the
voices in the panoramic lens the pancake
dreams were still there she's like the
starbucks siren yes no she is not no
come on
she's the worst i don't think she's a
bad looking older lady no no not what no
she's i mean she's a she's the spider
monkey
she's an old high prostitute yes high
old french [ __ ] yes like a like a like
a flight attendant yeah on pan am okay
or she'd be a good stand-in for hocus
pocus too so here's something else that
is going on before we get to our segment
uh on uh make my professor famous
teachers across the country suck you
know that but uh they're looking now to
their students this is something that
was different the dynamic has changed
remember how kids used to look to
parents for approval
or to you know tell them right from
wrong
no it's better to have them as friends
yeah well now it's better to have the
parents and the teachers asking students
to validate their existences sure
if you are a visibly out teacher
you need to keep doing what you're doing
because it matters and it is making a
difference because on the last day of
school i had a student come up to me and
say miss b
when i grow up i want to be a lesbian
like you because you are awesome
how'd she know and you know what
that felt
so good it's so important
to see representation and to see like
hey
she's doing okay i know i'll be okay no
you won't
that's the safe space
that is what we should all be working
for well the safe space is her uterus
when i grow up i want a scissor on a
couch yes exactly i love how hey i don't
know why is that a goal i've never once
told a child with whom or how i have sex
have you
comment below and you know what hit the
like button if you think that you
probably shouldn't be telling small
children about your sexual act no one
cares that you're a lesbian no one cares
that you shop at eddie bauer i'm a
little upset because she's cute we kind
of lost one to the other team whatever
that's your right i didn't know she was
a lesbian i didn't know when i first saw
her no i didn't know i think she's cute
yes
and then you understand what she does
and i don't mean her her i don't mean
her her muff diving i mean what she does
with children and it makes her repulsive
but she should have corrected the child
she's like i'm not awesome because i'm a
lesbian i'm awesome and happen to be a
lesbian right don't don't you know
causality the whole thing it's like come
on right scissors i'm not a lesbian
because i'm awesome i'm a lesbian
because my dad never hugged me enough
that's that's maybe yeah it should be
part of the curriculum it should be part
of the question and answer session
i mean look this is one of those things
where now they translate to conspiracy
theories that is grooming just so you
know you don't have to be a pedophile
and want you don't have to desire
sexually assaulting children just to be
clear sexualizing children by
introducing them to sexual topics is the
equivalent to grooming what does that
mean it means that you are now opening
their mind to the possibility of sexual
interactions that's not healthy it's not
a good thing it's also by the way while
we're talking about lesbian my parents
gave me the sex talk really young i've
talked about this they told me where
babies came from because they didn't
want me to believe the stork business
but i knew what it was so i understood
where babies came from yeah they didn't
talk about rose petals they didn't talk
about hammocks they just told me this is
how babies are made now when you're a
lesbian of course that's not how babies
are made and you need to do some
explaining why are you announcing it
i don't and here's what they'll say you
can't have it both ways well that's
because you don't have to i do why don't
i have to because i'm heteronormative oh
now we're stigmatizing you
just shut up
can we do that how about teaching and
making sure test scores go up first yes
just i don't know what just happened you
know let's start with the pregnancy test
yeah
i don't know you having your tubes tied
so you don't have to worry about it
just it's odd i don't i don't
what did she didn't how'd she know the
kids said i was awesome that's like
donald trump as a teacher the kids said
it was awesome yeah
not because of scissor not because they
scissor folks so i do says i do the best
scissor
i've been told i want to nail hot broads
like you donald yes
yeah it is pretty awesome
a plus the kid hands an art of the deal
too crayon i like your style yeah
closing the deal it's a picture of trump
at a bar
listen listen you kids better learn now
the best part
of falling down when the art of the
comeback is you get to screw everyone on
your way back up
nail them against the wall crucify them
crucify with great crucifier
shove wood chips up their thumbs you're
too young for this
but i digress uh oh uh sorry i'm
actually hearing right now um we do have
breaking news no
[Music]
uh this just in uh the queen of england
is still alive
[Music]
so uh you know this is i found out today
the queen of england is still left i
should know she's on our money
i didn't know your former country's
money my former docking yeah has she
looked that old as i x i always remember
her wild white-haired old yeah yeah yeah
no she came out
90 like freddy krueger yeah she's just
like that yes and look of course no one
wishes her any ill will no uh i from
what i understand she said he's the grim
reaper right yes
that's just his job yeah he's been
hovering over her it's just business why
are you rushing yeah well they always
are let's play chess
yeah
this is my job and if i do not fulfill
it then my children will not be able to
eat you have to be eliminated
just
just grab the scythe and kill me what do
you have to do what are you doing action
movie closing lines you could be brad
pitt you know we tried that
hey michael black yeah i have to kill
you but all right
now
that would excite her
just in the casket with the what's in
the box oh god
now queen
it's a queen oh oh god
so here's the thing though i actually i
do have some respect for this queen uh
and i i obviously am not a big fan of
the monarchy we kind of fought them off
that's a good part of our history i
would argue but uh here is something
that does bother me is not the queen
it's not the royal family i get that
they don't really have a choice
when people say we're more polarized
than ever and granted people will say
the show contributes to it sure
i see it as a counter balance i'm pretty
honest about my biases i just
i let you know i make all the references
available at lightworkcover.com i don't
claim to be an objective journalist
because nobody is
the reason we have to respond is because
shows networks that present themselves
as objective journalism politicize
everything in a subversive way see if
you can catch it here on cnn this
morning i was in the shower
watching tv i was in the shower and i
choked
when i heard this
unrelated
she has in terms of shaking hands um
counseled as well 15 prime ministers her
very first prime minister was winston
churchill so her whole public life
was was was was built
started in the shadow of the kind of war
that we're seeing a little bit of right
now the the assault on the rule of law
democracy um human rights that having to
stand up for
for
for for what can you say for for the for
the right for the right stuff and that's
how she was shaped and that's how she
has continued to live her life and and
to reign as queen with a sense of duty
despite everything else
for the right to wear silly hats
yes what to wear tim burton costumes
around town yes and cherry dogs they
have the same personal wardrobe stylist
as helena bottom carter
now
did you hear what they just did
they compared churchill i don't know if
you know this a little i don't know if
you're history buffs
she was banged by winston
no churchill fought off hitler yeah yeah
yeah yeah right world war ii and she's
having a very similar it's a very
similar wall now wait hold on a second i
don't even know that i understand
they're so reaching for a political
parallel i don't even understand it do
you mean that do you mean that sure
donald trump is not in power okay do you
mean to say that hitler was raided by
the ss equivalent of the fbi and sent
out mean press releases
do you mean to say that churchill
i i i don't even understand what is even
remotely similar right now to world war
ii and who's hitler
can you make sense of this can you guys
comment below i i genuinely don't
understand the point they were trying to
make this is do you know what they're
trying to say no but i also don't think
she does because she's like you know
standing up for um how how would you say
it i'm like i don't know you're the
reporter tell me how you would say it
like don't ask the audience
oh how does it affect her at all it's
like she was very rich and still is
nothing is bad for her yes and she's
been a figurehead most of her life and
uh prime ministers have really done the
worst thing she's ever had is a headache
i hope she's okay yes there's several
hundred people tending right now just
like every other day yes she gets
anything she wants all the time on your
money just does anyone know what the
comparison was
no i really don't understand like what
i
okay stupid it's just like churchill
fighting hitler by the way do you know
that churchill was ousted very quickly
afterwards do you know why primarily
because he opposed socialized healthcare
i guess the queen's hitler in the
scenario i guess
murdering jews yeah i just wanted
everyone to know nobody believes me and
prince charles is uh the jew in the
attic eating porridge yes yeah they're
here for me perhaps some
soft cheeses yeah is that is he has very
soft teeth prince john yes he does he
must have his chew his food chewed and
spit into his mouth like a baby bird
he's been waiting 70 years for his
chance unfortunately the queen
can't chew either so they have a they
have a midwife who spits into his mouth
oh jesus they have a gorgeous blending
every christmas
people dressed as birds
god save the queen finest turkeys and
hams god save the queen not cnn okay
speaking of drama queens let's move on
to aoc here this is obviously trending
everywhere i wish we didn't have to
acknowledge her
unfortunately we do
uh so gq released their october uh this
cover story on aoc yes because
aoc
should be the cover story of gentlemen's
quarterly yes and immediately lost
subscribers yes
all right did you see the cover yeah
well i wonder why these magazines aren't
doing the sports illustrated swimsuit
edition now includes transgender land
whales and aoc is going to teach you
what kind of a tie to wear i always like
my hot girls with a penis yes
it's a genre thank you sports
illustrated
so they released their cover story on
aoc and uh it's it's it's it's a
psychopathic just to be clear she is i i
will say this i believe that she is a
narcissistic sociopath now let me
substantiate that all references
available at earthquaker.com here's the
introduction to the article is i would
say an example
uh almost four years after her
improbable arrival in washington
congresswoman alexandria casa cortez has
become the political voice of a
generation
and a cultural star whose power
transcends politics well here's the
thing they say that but i'll go on to
they say she's the voice of a generation
but she says she can't become president
ah i don't know wouldn't the voice of a
generation you know represent a
generation
not a district not in this case where
the guy refused to show up for a debate
and didn't really run
by the way if that doesn't sum up the
mood maybe the photo shoot will do the
trick
nice set of hooters you got there
did you see the cover she's dressed like
wesley snipes in new jack city it's just
so creepy you see the options they
didn't pick it's the demolition man
haircut yeah yeah
i wanna i wanna just like time cop yeah
well
we have all these wesley and van damme
choices for you aoc pick freely and your
big goofy cartoon eyes bloodsport 2 is
scratched out says gq
she looks like a caricature like she
should always be kicking a soccer ball
or holding an ice cream cone look at
that that is wesley snipes no no no look
look look she wants all women to
understand that you are beautiful by
airbrushing the crap out of her pictures
i want a seven button steve harvey suit
yes
[Laughter]
with the cedric the entertainer yes
i hate her so uh here's her discussing
her were you about citizen gerald no
okay her presidential hopes he was he
he's biting he's biting his tongue
her presidential hopes in this article
and then we'll get to the reason why
people like this are dangerous and it's
not because you saw that with the queen
right here's the through line yeah even
if you like the queen maybe the queen
isn't so bad aoc is bad don't like her
but the media is going to use the queen
how they want to use the queen
to compare churchill
i guess to biden and trump to hitler not
exactly sure they decide to use it as a
jumping off point the same thing with
aoc gq is going to use her to say she's
a voice of a generation the media will
use these people because they are not in
the business of actually reporting
on what matters or what you care about
they want to engineer what you care
about what you think if there's nothing
else that you glean from the show aside
from entertainment it i hope
that it's how
to think how to question how to reason
don't just take these opinions don't
take it as carte blanche just go off and
say well this is what they said check
the references you can be as educated as
you want you can have a cursory view we
covered on this or you can go and do a
deep dive in every single reference the
media will use these people as they see
fit chew them up and spit them out as
you see with david hogg as you see with
gretenberg if aoc doesn't win another
election guess what they won't care
about her anymore they'll find someone
else to try and tell you that you like
them so here's what aoc said about her
presidential hopes
sometimes little girls say oh i want you
to be president or things like that
good it's very difficult for me to talk
about because it provokes a lot of inner
conflict and that i never want to tell
little girl what she can't do
i don't want to tell young people what
is not possible i've never been in the
business of doing that okay good that's
it yeah but at the same time
i hold two contradictory things in mind
at the same time one is just the
relentless belief that anything is
possible
but at the same time jesus like three
times
my experience here has given me a front
row seat to how deeply and unconsciously
as well as consciously
so many people in this country hate
women what they hate women of color oh
boy people you're like a tope people ask
me questions about the future and
realistically i can't even tell you if
i'm going to be alive in september
i can't even tell you if i'm going to be
alive because quote this country hates
women
no
just you and you just happen however
i'll be in the september issue of
gentlemen's quarterly yes where i'm very
much alive yes maybe and i'm going to be
in playboy in a wetsuit yes
because there's no nudity in that
there's no nudity anymore
thick puppies by the way uh just to note
maybe a reason that she may not run for
brother it's not because all of you hate
women
uh it's because she's
actually sponsored
i'm trying to let me i want to make sure
i get the numbers don't forget the yeah
carry the one zero successful bills
i know you're thinking wait some none i
know what you're thinking
one
no
so you have to be a successful
politician to be president you would
think so no no no no no no you don't
barack obama voted present to like some
very no no but barack obama did actually
have some bills he did have some the
standard has lowered it has i know
here's the problem hold on a second
everyone reset your brain you're
thinking some yeah yeah what i'm saying
is none
hold out your hands jerry yes in a cup
formation don't spoil your dinner see
what's in your hand
that's what she has yes
that's what she has contributed to
society if hey
just
okay here's what i want you to do if you
think that she might not be president
because everyone hates women
do nothing if you think it's because she
sponsored zero successful bills hit the
like button that helps with the
algorithm let aoc know because she does
watch this show
she's responded and not even just to
tweet she's responded to things that are
buried in the show hit the like button
so she can see how much you love her and
here's one thing i do want to say
um
i wish women
i wish women could
could see yourselves away men's for you
men don't hate women we love women of
course men almost as much as that
lesbian teacher we love women we
desperately want women to be women
femininity is dying and it's because of
fem it's because of people like aoc and
you're more miserable than ever men
don't hate you for example if you look
at the women's magazines i was just
talking with someone about this the
other day you know this uh you think
we're all supposed to look like that i
go that's cosmopolitan
no no man expects you to look like that
one decade the most beautiful woman in
this country was marilyn monroe big girl
next decade audrey hepburn petite girl
we find both of them attractive
okay we have a very wide spectrum we
just ask that you're a woman and you
know what is a good quality being nice
aoc is not nice are you saying that
women need to be nice no you don't have
to be anything only if you want a man if
you want men to like you being nice is
equality that we really value aoc nancy
pelosi they're not nice people
and i do mean kindness warmth i just
wish that women understood how much men
love them and want them to be the woman
they were designed to be it doesn't come
from a place of hate and if we can't
stand aoc it has nothing to do with the
fact that she's
a woman
i love [ __ ] yes
i'm more of a hose man myself
so she did try to introduce bills uh
there's a total of 21 bills
um that the center uh defined as
substantive this comes from the new york
post well baseball is toxic so 21
strikes is fine her legislation received
no action in committees no floor votes
and none ever became law uh
snaggletoothed drunk and stupid is no
way to go through life sweetheart
now it does get a little bit better she
does think that a lot of the bills that
ended up making it in passing and
legislation that has passed that is
included her language has been taken and
no credit has been given to her i'm not
even kidding the green new deal she
thinks biden right now is basically
saying this is the green new deal
language and i i wrote that is what she
says in the article i i love hearing it
come from his mouth but the only way it
happens is because he's a man and he's
president saying it and if i get up
there and say it nobody's going to
listen because i'm a woman not because
it's a bad idea maybe because you lie
about everything did they add the word
like to the bill four thousand times yes
that'd be a short school house rock
there's only 14 15 pages i'm just a bill
now i'm stuck in committed you didn't
make it to committee no sorry so i go to
the senate and you didn't get to the
senate oh [ __ ] i'm not allowed in
[Laughter]
my bills are awful
i can't pay them either i was written by
aoc so i sit here and wait
where all the pedophiles continue to
groom and debate
i was written with colored pencils
oh i'm waiting for a lesbian teacher oh
i hope and pray that she will
the bill is gay don't say it really
by the way she has though she has done
her part uh at least five high-profile
magazine covers oh okay yeah
i'm working on wood
and that one she's wearing the american
hustle glasses yeah just like in a wood
shop why now let me explain to you why
aoc will never be present again has
nothing to it has nothing to do with the
fact that she's a woman there are lots
of women
in politics who have been successful
yeah uh
thatcher is one of them as an example
very strong unfortunately gretchen
whitmer is governor there in uh in
michigan new prime minister of england
is a woman
now is that true yes oh they're going
just happen
the reason why is because a that's i
need to check myself aoc is a sociopath
and i don't want a diagnosis this isn't
a formal diagnosis like the lady at yale
who diagnosed donald trump and then lost
her spot
i think she's a sociopathic narcissistic
liar let me give you some examples on
june 24 2019 remember she staged that
photo shoot at the migrant camp
by the way in case you know she was just
looking at uh she was looking at some
cruisers a parking lot
is that where she was yeah she was in
front of an empty lot an empty road uh
then of course she also said this is
just the greatest hits january 12th aoc
said that she almost died at the capitol
riot almost died
you know what else everybody like puffy
sorry this is the one different
i had a pretty traumatizing event happen
to me
um
and i do not know
anything if i can even disclose the full
details of that event why not due to
security concerns come on
but i can tell you that i had a very
close
encounter where i thought i was going to
die yeah blocks away um
and
you have all of those thoughts this is
like watching the office the way it's
being delivered where
at the
and all of these thoughts come rushing
to you the first time and
um
that's what happened to a lot of us on
wednesday
um
and
i thought i i did not think
i did not know if i was going to make it
to the end of that day of life no it's i
don't think therefore i am aoc
we now know the story i was several
buildings away yes but you know i i
wasn't sure if i was gonna make it and i
was confused because i had thoughts
rushing in and i said what are those my
whole life flash before my eyes well i
was just making a cosmopolitan
do you remember what she said somebody
tried to break into her office yes and
it was a police officer to get her out
of the building trying to tell her to
shut up
who are you stop live streaming
you can hear her walking oh that was her
in time cop oh right
so look look if you're not getting the
picture yet that's another one and by
the way the re this is also very telling
the reason that that's so distorted is
because of the fact that you can't
really find the original clip and on
instagram it's distorted the comments
are suspended it's one of those things
that doesn't auto-play it is very very
difficult to find
so they don't delete it
but they do everything they can to make
it unsearchable and of course they have
their buddies in big tech by the way
we're going to get some more news on
that as far as big tech you just saw
that just happened a judge said you have
to release it oh yeah yeah information
here we continue december 31st 2021 uh
after she was criticized for vacationing
in florida
she claimed that republic just like we
all hate women the only reason she was
criticized there is because republicans
just want to date her
oh if republicans are um
mad they can't date me and they can just
say that instead of projecting their
sexual frustrations onto my boyfriend's
feet so we shouldn't know she's a foot
fetish yeah creepy weirdos and here's
the thing
i know people always mock like oh yo
straight white mill you really had it
hard you've been in charge hold on a
second as a straight white male we can
never use a card like that yeah none
where it's like hey you suck at your job
well is that just because you want to
take me out for dinner i'm like what are
you talking what the hell are you
talking about stephen women get to say
that this is what happens then they say
people hate women because people do
attack her based on her using gender as
a shield women don't be fooled by it you
need to start calling these people to
the mat because if we say anything and i
get it men we have a lot of women who
work here by the way and they're
actually more of it one of the women who
works at you know one of them that works
back there i don't want to out her she
doesn't think women should have the
right to vote what let's see if we can
bring her on the show and never talk
about it she said it the other night
that was shocked and she i said oh why
do you think why do you think a lot of
women didn't want to vote
and i was going to answer because of
bucket duty like we talked about because
of the draft and her answer was she said
because they're crazy emotional and
irrational
[Laughter]
and i said
no
i didn't say that
[Laughter]
i was very surprised she made a very
compelling case
but women we can't call them to the mat
we can't call those because then they
say oh this is because i'm a woman no no
no it's because you're a liar oh is it
because you want to date me
not on my deathbed not on my queen bed i
would never
want to date you okay it has nothing to
do with that
what do you think this is kindergarten
yeah plus i'm totally into her
boyfriend's feet yes yeah i don't want
anything with her i don't want to i
don't want to lay at your boyfriend's
feet i want to lay on your boyfriend's
feet
i want to use them any way i want if
that makes us a creepy weirdo your quote
then well is guilty isn't he a straight
white
guy well she said that might be a
problem too oh should it might be a
problem that you might not be the right
fit because he's a straight white male
oh i see well go find yourself a trans
el salvadorian gang member see how it
works out there you go july 19th
2012 down to the bronx
july 19th 2022 aoc of course this is
another one so what do we have we have i
was attacked at the capitol well that
was completely untrue we have it's
because you hate women that was complete
of course that's a complete red earring
we have oh it's because uh you want to
date me we have the migrant camp into an
empty lot are you starting to see
the lack of accountability from the
media the more recent one was where she
pretended to be even idea how elaborate
these lies are pretended to be
handcuffed for half a city block at the
roe v wade protest believe you're lying
eyes
[Music]
it's houdini
and behind her back
please nobody hit her in the oak plank
liar oh and then she puts her hand up
hmm
but it's just how i'm walking
yes every one of the squad that was
arrested decided to walk that way
because that's how people normally walk
right and weren't arrested think about
that you know no i will say this it is
because you're a woman in politics and
people are afraid to question you
because you constantly say that they're
a sexist just like people are often
afraid to for example get into crime
statistics enter gang-related violence
in urban areas in this country because
they'll be accused of being a racist so
it is because you are a woman that you
get that special treatment
that would turn any man into a mockery
and they would never win reelection
absolutely as it should but we and we
discussed this the other day where the
media basically will just feed off of
itself because this story is now true
right so she's being painted as this
hero of the progressive movement a voice
of a generation by a magazine and so now
cnn and every other news agency out
there other than maybe fox is going to
pick that up and run with it the voice
of this new generation that's going to
be the thing that kind of echoes around
but you fall for every lie along the way
every live tax the rich dress that she
wore at a gala that was like what twenty
thousand dollars for a ticket to go to
it right and now she's driving her tesla
as she's telling us stories about all
these you know i i was raped i have no
idea if she was that is horrific but it
seemed opportunistic when she told the
story right we fall for all these things
from politicians and then we elevate her
beyond that's another example look
people are going to get mad they're
going to say you're attacking the victim
no if aoc was raped that's terrible no i
will tell you this i want a man
any man so if a man raped aoc i want him
buried beneath the railroad tracks now
the way to help women and not be
opportunistic
is to come forward when that happens and
to have that man charged and convicted
yes my issue is with women who don't and
who go out and then claim something and
say but because it's my it's my truth i
i i don't want to go to the authorities
look this is a perfect example it's
uncomfortable
i understand that it's uncomfortable i
don't understand what it's like to be
raped just to be clear but it is the
right thing to do yeah you were wronged
you were absolutely wrong the right
thing to do if you care about women to
prevent that that rapist is still out
there aoc it's that simple he's still
out there and he could be out there in
the municipality where you want to
disarm women and you want to prevent
them from owning guns that's evil it's
all that is required for evil to
flourish is for people to act selfishly
that's what happens now but then
instead of self-reflection they get to
simply say
oh no i've done no wrong you're just
saying that because i'm a woman no i'm
not saying you should have reported the
rapist and have him convicted because
you're a woman i'm saying that that's
the right thing to do because i have a
daughter right and by the way it was the
guy she was dating at the time
she said it was a guy that she was
dating at the time that they just hadn't
gone that far and she's if she didn't
want to go that far that is still rape
it doesn't matter if they were no
absolutely but they need to find them
fake handcuff them yeah the problem that
i have though with it is the timing
right i think it's fake sodomized
oh no the old phantom sodomy trick
because she said it i'm gonna get out
behind these bars
i'm sorry gerald you're a bright man
i just it's though it goes to the whole
story like i don't know that i can
believe her on anything because of all
of the fake things that she's done she
said it in regards to roe v wade when
the decision came out not when the paper
was leaked when we all knew the decision
was coming not to put pressure on the
justices to maybe change their minds she
said it when it came out and said the
reason i thought about this is because i
i needed to tell the story now because i
thought at the time at least i have the
option to get an abortion that's how she
tied it together and if she had just if
that's the only story i ever heard from
aoc i would be like okay i understand
but because i know she has lied several
times because i know she's an
opportunist because i know she has
staged photo ops i can't trust anything
she says yeah can i uh am i allowed to
speculate on my own show that you just
like speculated about the queen she's
it's like hitler and church or something
let me speculate i think she's lying i
think i think she's lying about the rape
i think she's lying about the pregnancy
test why because the only examples that
i have of her making claims where there
is video evidence she's always lied
whether it's
looking into a migrant camp she didn't
whether it's being handcuffed and
arrested that never happened so i tend
to believe based on her pattern of
behavior that she's lying about if i had
to bet my life gun to my head i don't
know
i would bet she's lied about that why
because it's a convenient lie where
there can never be any verification or
accountability i took a pregnancy test
in a public stall
i get whatever you say guys i don't say
whatever you say say whatever you say is
likely a lie guys i have the pregnancy
test right here oh
it's the hook pregnancy you should stop
you should stop peeing on those okay it
doesn't work
it's all over them it just shows if you
have yeah yeah by the way you might have
prostate cancer that should not be a
blue line no
or your royalty certainly not a rainbow
well it's either blue or red depending
on the day yes
that nuclear warning symbol there that's
not
standard i only time i see yellow is
when i stare at the sun
how else are you going to see the
eclipse all right we have to do the
midterms thing tomorrow are you saying
we have ruby already uh no i was going
to say we have ruby in just a few
minutes but in the paywall he's still
coming on wow they they just sent me a
video that aoc made in college to uh was
that my life is this the dancing yeah on
the roof yeah where she's dancing on the
roof yeah that's so sexy i mean what
i mean
okay we could let's show it because
because she's a woman yeah it's gross
and wrong
good thing i'm sitting are you gonna
play if that was my cue
[Applause]
is there audio
wait
what is that jersey that's nothing it
says boston and it's red and white like
a red wings
oh yeah now i remember
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
[Music]
stop doing white man overbite too
what year is this why are they dressed i
don't know it was a very bad year
does this get any better can we shut
this off
the rape
no
what what happened what are you saying
nothing was that was after that yeah i
bet you it's the guy with the red hair
who did it yep
again while we're speculating it must be
nice to live in a world where nothing
can be verified yeah wait hold on you're
questioning what that's was it because
i'm uh canadian is it because i'm french
canadian it's because my first language
is french
but we've been dealing with this for
years
it's just so can we just get to the
point where we all look let's just
question the ideas let's sit here and
rationalize our own arguments it's it's
so tiring
to have to deal with because i'm a woman
uh sure yeah don't ask me to believe
everything you say let's go with that
yes yes no it's not it's not because
you're a socialist in a five-page bill
that takes over a third two-thirds of
the economy it's because of tits sure
now let's move on to this uh the uh
memphis shooting horrible tragedy that
took place yesterday um it was a 19 year
old psychopath and just to be clear i
want to make sure we change it the clip
that we have does not show any of the
shooting right no okay good good good uh
because you never want to give this i
don't even want i don't want to give his
name nope
unfortunately we do have to show the mug
shot because it is relevant
uh so a 19-year-old psychopath he's
already been caught he killed four
injured three lasted from 1 a.m to 9 30
p.m
uh i mean you know it's at least it's
not as bad as canada where it goes on
for days well that's true
with a rapier uh here's a clip
on wagons
so real mind guys
uh okay now here's something else that i
think is important
the gunman was taken rightfully so even
though i hope that as we go through the
legal process if he's found guilty he
gets fried
but at this point in time he was
appropriately taken into custody alive
[Music]
now i say this because this is important
here is you've heard this all over the
news um because they want to see just
like aoc wants to see everything through
the lens of
gender sorry sex because gender isn't
male female man woman i don't know the
language anymore
wants you to see it through the the
fisheye lens of titties uh they also
want you to see the media everything
through the lens of race meaning if
someone is a shooter uh
who is black okay well then we
immediately have to
categorize it as this is not racially
motivated or if a shooter is taken into
custody by police officers we've heard
this many times and they're
black well it's ignored but they will
recite statistics or they'll use
anecdotal evidence to try and suggest
that black men are always taken into
custody uh well actually not taken into
custody i mean to say that they're shot
by police officers violently while white
men are gently taken into custody right
there we just now see if you can
understand maybe why the reason he was
taking sure he killed people he was
surrendering to the police just like
dylann roof piece of crap i hope that he
gets i hope he gets lethal uh lethal
injection
but there's a difference between a
shootout with police officers
versus surrendering yeah it's not a race
thing
it's a behavior thing in that specific
moment in time this gunman was taken
into custody live but here's the media
when you surrender
yeah he was there he was not he was
non-violent with the police officers
okay when they took him into custody
okay that's the key piece of information
that the problem is the media never
actually focuses on that and you've seen
this let me just just so you believe
your lion eyes and your lion ears here's
the myth they've tried to perpetuate for
a long time there's also a stark double
standard in policing here because when
faced with the deadliest shooting of the
year and a suspect who is literally
still holding a gun
used to allegedly kill
10 innocent people
well at that
moment
police were at the highest
possible legal threshold
for firing a weapon
for using deadly force
and they didn't
by contrast two months ago buffalo
police used deadly force on dominique
thomas shooting him when he had a mental
health episode and was reportedly seen
with a knife last year buffalo okay this
is enough to get the point by the way
did someone put a someone put a flat
iron on the top of that guy's head
so it's two different police forces too
it's not even comparable right the the
constant through line is if you
surrender non-violent yeah but
non-violently in general you're taken
into custody
peacefully not always in general
regardless of race now
why if you look at a blanket statistic
for example we've talked about this in
the past and people have tried to say
that we were wrong
black armed black men are actually less
likely to be shot by police officers
than armed white men now the statistic
is skewed if you just say black men
versus white men why because unarmed
black men that is true are more likely
to be shot
but for the same reason that in many of
these examples of these men being
brought into custody
the reason that unarmed black men are
shot more often than unarmed white men
and excuse of statistics is that nearly
40 percent of all assaults on police
officers
or by
largely black men some black women they
make up only 13 of the population
and here's also an issue um
we don't know how accurate that is
because specifics of race and crime
they're now hard to find 2008 the bureau
of justice stopped publishing data on
interracial crime i wonder why
so just to be clear
these stat that you can massage these
statistics how you want and people do
that but armed black men
less likely to be shot than uh than
armed white men okay unarmed black men
more likely to be shot because they
commit an exponentially higher rate of
assault against officers not because
they're black
we need to examine why that is the case
why that is happening how what we can do
to address it because what we've been
doing has not worked
but the constant through line let's try
and distill it i don't think that it's
reductive i think distilling something
is well it seems as though if you're
violent with the police you're more
likely to have a violent uh a violent
conclusion yeah well that's what the
police officers have said it always
comes down to behavior right jacob blake
would probably fit into that statistic
as an unarmed black man that was shot by
cops but he was also trying to get to a
knife well okay it's very interesting
that you brought that up by the way this
kid already had a rap shoot a mile long
at the age of 17. two counts of
attempted murder reckless endangerment
possession of a firearm all this okay
references
you mentioned jacob blake yeah for those
of you who don't remember jacob blake
was the man who was shot by police
officers uh and they tried to say a
black man being shot by police officers
because he's black now if you don't
remember jacob blake and this was on
video
a woman called the police for help
because jacob blake was kidnapping his
own children
the woman who called already had a
restraining order on jacob blake because
he sexually assaulted her she was the
mother of those children jacob blake not
only resisted arrest not only tried to
reach for a knife as the police officers
were at first non-violently trying to
subdue him but had found himself at this
situation so many times before that he
had a knife carved out in his
floorboards
i didn't know that they put it under the
mat the point is he had a safe place for
his nice for his knife for the fuzz he
was used to it had a rap sheet a mile
long as well so that was jacob blase and
blake in case you've forgotten it also
by the way contributed to more riots
just to be clear jacob blake till we
found out the rest of the story now that
brings us to the memphis mayor
now you know let me let me start the
memphis mayor okay
uh he's i believe now we also uh he has
a there's a quote here from the memphis
mayor but there's also a d.a steve
mulroy
who's allegedly backed by by soros i
don't know that but
the d.a
endorsed by jacob lake senior oh
seriously
by the way crime is up uh you know
40 in major urban cities since
pre-pandemic levels just to be clear so
it harms you the average american but i
think i know why
because you hate women here's the mayor
blaming the judicial system as opposed
to the psychopath who shot people at
random
ezekiel kelly
was charged
with criminal
attempted first degree murder
but pled guilty
in april of 2021
to the lesser charge of aggravated
assault
he was sentenced
to three years
but only served
11 months
in prison the problem is not the memphis
police department because they're
arresting people the problem is this
judicial system that will not punish
that is our problem
but just to be clear i actually agree
with him on that what he's saying there
yeah he's blaming he's he's talking
about the judicial system as opposed to
police officer so i should have set that
up more appropriate i don't really i'm
just bothered that he looks like he
should be in the third act of slither
[Music]
[Laughter]
something's wrong with me
it's gorbachev without the
silly painted face yes
garbage have tear down this string
cheese so what do they call that the
what kind port wine
birthmark
what do they call it i don't know the
birth marquee that's what i've had yeah
yeah i know that i just don't know i
didn't know it was related to a port
wine well i figured you would know going
back to this guy business are you in
i've never wanted a perp to reach for a
gun when the cops showed up more in my
life yeah than saying like that's pure
evil yeah i'm live streaming this i'm
going i'm gonna go and you think guys do
you think i'm joking around you think
i'm random person going about their day
probably going home to a wife and kids
that they're working to support probably
not the easiest thing to do in that
neighborhood that he was in probably a
low-income neighborhood from what i saw
in that video
and then you shoot them for no reason
whatsoever other than you're a
psychopath hey uh by the way you know
what um i'm gonna make a i i we have no
knowledge of this at this point right
now or at least i don't
hit the like button if you would be
willing to make this prediction too how
much you want to bet
probably not a dad in the home
at least not an involved father if at
all how much do you want to bet that is
a consistent through line it's not that
these people aren't psychotropic
medication though sometimes it's not
that these people come from impoverished
areas though sometimes it's not that
they're black though sometimes it's not
that they're white supremacists
though sometimes if rarely a consistent
through line is usually gun-free zones
and of course they often don't have
fathers
how much you want to bet
hit that like button if you're willing
to make that prediction
because that that hitting of the like
button is saying uh we need dads in the
home let's start with that
let's start when people say what
difference how can i make it it starts
with you it starts with you as a father
as a son as a brother
as a husband
that's what this kid needed
and what does he need now
dose of the lethal injection yeah
uh and you know what look things aren't
things aren't as bad in the country as
the media necessarily want you to
believe though i will say they are bad
and that's why um you know uh
i do have a fallout shelter
[Music]
sup homie underneath the last uh
chocolate pudding if that's cool
uh that's not cool
let's split it
no you didn't split the last creamy
macaroni and cheese with me
gum war no i almost died last time
rock paper scissors hell no
[Music]
chicken
[Music]
yes so go to prep with crowder.com for
250 off a three-month emergency food kit
or don't but just god forbid there's
like a flood
or an ice storm
where you can't charge your tesla in
california just go to prep with
crowder.com you get a discount
there you go prep with crowder.com to
get a three-month emergency food supply
kit that's like 48 000 ratings nice of
four and five-star ratings and by the
way thank you very much they came to the
spokane show and they gave me a bunch of
extra oatmeal it is legitimately better
than quaker
i'm not going to say the rest of their
food is fine cuisine it's it's in case
there's a fallout their oatmeal is
better than quaker oatmeal or or if
you're in california it happens to be
hot yeah yeah where you charge your
tesla with a gas generator
by the way is that the pallet we
received delivery from them a pallet of
oatmeal really that's a lot yes the
pudding made me dance yep well we put
some stuff
out
that was more so what i did with the
pudding uh and uh what by the way this
is one thing did you just yeah they're a
sponsor okay they have the balls to
sponsor this show i'm not a prep a
doomsday guy just to be i lived through
the ice storm i've talked about this you
have things that happen in california we
had the freeze here in texas texas yeah
not to mention
covid right who would have thought
that in the 21st century you wouldn't be
able to get toilet paper so just having
enough food for three months having some
water
i i always rec i can do it now because
there was a shortage before i didn't
want to ever clear yeah high proof
alcohol it's something that's
multi-purpose you can use it to
disinfect you can also use it to trade
with drunks
when you're on the road
zombies tend to like it too all right i
don't know if we're gonna have uh
senator rubio on the show he has not
called in yet so uh let's continue on
with uh
the next segment oh by the way i should
also tell you uh i used to not be able
to recommend uh cigars yeah and the
reason for that was because you guys
would buy all of them
and it's a finite product
it's a leaf you wouldn't recommend the
ones you loved that was the thing you
could probably the secret you did so i
did want to mention actually uh it's not
a sponsor but if you go to cigars
daily.com we have a promo code right now
internet and crowder you get 15 off they
have this 10 count box of uh and dave
likes these millennials
actually yeah those are really good
they're small they're fine and it's 10
count boxes you don't have to like get
25. it's one of my favorites the only
reason i'm able to recommend it is
because i have they're not a sponsor but
i have a guaranteed supply well and he's
a friend of the show and he's a good guy
he's a friend of the show and he just
pays me by allowing me to be able to
purchase cigars without a shortage
they're good yeah pretty delicious all
right i'm stealing one let's move on to
this we have had this segment here for a
while i don't think we'll be able to get
to a senator rubio if he's we'll see
because well the problem is i have to do
this once i start this segment i can't
cut it
it's like peeing once you start you
can't stop look i don't have anything
against you
senator rubio
anyone but if you want to come on to the
show
bill maher
as well billy just you know work within
the parameters that's the marks william
i'm all right
i'll tell you off there something
happened there oh did it yeah there's an
update
listen
all right
so saucy i want to lead this with
uh teacher tips at louderwithcrowder.com
okay we started we've started this
segment uh well i don't know a few
months ago and it just took us a while
to follow up because we've had you know
the time and i've had this stuff
vet things
uh but now it's up and running full
steam and we want you to have an outlet
we get so many emails so many texts not
texts we don't give about our number
well toolman does
well
um a lot of a lot of pictures of aoc's
husband's feet lanes
posting it call me ladies again teacher
tits at loudwithcrowder.com goes to me
tonight just come on in these people
know what's going on what do you just
tell me um so i think the call is
connected we're just getting him up and
running oh oh
well we just i mean if we get him up and
running the problem here is the fella if
you called yeah i guess all right gerald
take this for a second i'm gonna light
this together oh you're probably just
too stressful for me teacher tips later
on how about this let's just are you
[ __ ] me
are you [ __ ] me spider
i've stolen all your butane it's your
lighter lighter okay here we got him on
we need a runner johnny boy
that's the one thing i asked him i said
can you just make sure i had this half
full i asked him to make it all the way
full looks like it it doesn't but it
doesn't matter if it looks like it well
aoc looks like she thinks that's true
and we you know we just showed it it
matters all right solar all empty we do
have senator rubio
all right okay well then let's uh hit
the stinger because uh senator rubio uh
is now
on the show
[Music]
all right senator marco rubio can you
hear me see me sir
yeah i can hear you and well i can't see
you
oh okay well i can't see you oh i need
to get you up on this thing here i know
it's a whole bunch of tech issues today
well thank you for being by the way
people can follow you on twitter at
marco rubio thanks for being here
and just know i got pants on too because
sometimes when you do these things
people think oh he must be in short
still it's 11
10 man that those days are over well i
don't know if those are uh short pants
or not you only showed the hip so i have
no idea all right there you go well next
thing i'm going to add right there i'm
going to ask to see the uh the garters
uh so you know what
oh man i'm not there yet maybe before i
just got an arp card in the middle that
was pissed really
yeah you turn 50 they start sending you
that and you know all kinds of ads for
colonoscopies and stuff so
i'm really
not in a good mood that wasn't an ad
that was a telegram from dave so i
apologize you could rsvp i would
appreciate it yes yes also advice never
get a colonic that you found on
craigslist i learned that one or coupons
um hey
before i get into anything national uh
senator rubio you know you did something
there that's pretty rare in in florida
and i want to ask you about this you
know tobacco is sort of the third rail
in politics because there's been such a
strong anti-tobacco lobby and they they
sort of lump everything in with
cigarettes right and um cigars was
something that was affected obviously in
your home state of florida and a lot of
people don't know that these cigars are
very different right there's these are
premium products where it's only a leaf
tobacco and often they're mom and pop
businesses these rollers uh you played a
big role in saving the hand rolled cigar
industry in in florida can you kind of
explain that to people because a lot of
moms might go i don't like that he likes
tobacco so that's not what it's about
yeah no it isn't well first of all i say
three things that i have so my
grandfather like you know he uh
basically you know was raised in the
tobacco industry not as a girl or
whatever in fact he had polio when he
was young so he was the only one of his
listen to the 17 kids in the family they
had their own labor program going
because they're on the countryside and
had 17 kids he was the only one that
couldn't work it because he had polio so
he used to read to these guys that would
roll the cigars in cuba
and so i have a long history that i'm a
cigar smoker myself not as much as i'd
like because then i you know i get
screamed at for smelling up the house
but um but the the fix to that senator
is you smoke outside it's not
complicated but it's like 108 degrees in
florida in the summer but now you're
right that's the answer to it so
it's an important industry it also is an
important history to the tampa bay area
city like there's a long history there's
one company left so the fda comes out
with this rule and basically the rule
would make it impossible uh for you know
every they they require any every new
product
to have a new studies done on the
carcinogens well that's impossible for
cigars because every year is different
the leaves are different the
you know it's the same product grown in
the same place by the same people but
from year to year there are varieties
right sometimes people care about the
year of the product so these premium
cigars would not be able to compete and
it's not just the cigar
growers and manufacturers that would be
impacted by it's the retail shops all
the smoke shops would basically be wiped
out because you just wouldn't be able to
buy this stuff because you can't label
these things the way they're asking them
to right so it wipes out this industry
so i don't think they were the intended
they were certainly not the intended
target of the rule but they were
captured in it right and trying to fix
it became impossible because no one
wanted as you said wanted to touch it
and you and so this is not cigarettes
these are premium cigars some of which
go for ten dollars per cigar the boxes
are certainly very expensive there's
just zero evidence that in america today
there's an epidemic of teenagers buying
120 boxes of cigars well and that's
important to note because it was
predicated on the idea of eliminating
you know
smoking and youth and what they did they
pulled this kind of trick where they
just included you know for example like
swisher sweets things that you get at a
gas station which are really cigarettes
in the shape of cigars there's a legal
definition of hand rolled means there
can only be one product in it tobacco
leaves period one ingredient different
kinds of leaves for a blend it's just a
completely different
market and then on top of it it's like
12 year olds aren't smoking 16 cigars
yes yeah i mean it's like you know
comparing you know uh some you know
cheap beer to some expensive french wine
or something
the bottom line being is that it's just
not the kind of thing you're gonna find
at a convenience store and it's
certainly not the kind of thing and then
there's a cultural aspect that people
just don't get if you're not a cigar
smoker you just don't know but you don't
smoke cigars the way you do cigarettes
you don't smoke a box of cigars a day it
just doesn't happen right
you might
well you know that's a lot of cigars for
me i don't know if you have enough time
in the day a good cigar may take an hour
if you do it right so you just add it up
i mean you basically have to spend your
waking hour so and maybe somebody does
but it's not it's quite rare so the
point being is that this not the product
is just not consumed the same way that's
a fact and and even the medicine behind
it you know all the statistical studies
say you know you're just exclusively a
cigar smoker risk is not zero of course
uh but the risk this risk of driving is
not zero either in fact it's
substantially higher right and and so
yeah nonetheless we all drive well
it's also interesting too that of course
the left when they talk about this is
actually when you look at the cigar
industry it's one of the few ways that
people even in south american countries
who of course partner with american
companies can actually get decent paying
jobs because it's considered a very
valuable skill
and as a matter of fact i would love to
talk with you at some point about this
you know tim at cigars daily who's a
friend of mine they've had a real
problem with rollers in these south
american countries now because of the
open border and a lot of these people
have been now coming through they can't
find people to roll cigars at this point
which is yeah that is primarily
important in honduras in the dominican
republic and in nicaragua especially in
nicaragua yeah which is the one though
he's been hit by that and look that's a
real complicated skill right i mean it
takes a lot of skill to do that it's not
the kind of thing you can do if you did
it by machine it wouldn't be the nobody
would buy it i tried it once at a party
it was really bad
it's hard you got to cut it with this it
uh and that's the people my grandfather
used to read to back in cuba in the turn
of the century because they had no
television at that time or anything to
entertain them so the way they would
keep people entertained is they had this
reader who would read the newspapers and
then he would read some novel to them so
that's what he did and then when he was
done he'd make some extra money by
actually rolling cigars oh well very so
you have a long history i wondered why
that was something that you you know you
championed pretty by the way effectively
okay let me move on to stuff that
affects uh people who right now the
non-cigar smokers are like
barring until they realize that it
affects whatever it is they like i don't
know uh chris crystal vapes
uh let me ask you what did you think
about uh former vice president joe
biden's the the v for vendetta-esque
speech last week we talked about it on
this show
what were your thoughts have you ever
seen anything like that in your life no
i haven't not in the united states
i think this this notion that there's a
difference between saying you know
attack a political opponent i think
we've all sort of understood that now
and has seen it you know we've seen
vitriol at certain levels in this
country and it is what it is
but this is not what he did what he
basically
he didn't attack uh a pres a figure he
attacked voters exactly in florida he
attacked you know the majority of voters
because trump won florida by three and a
half almost four points nationally he
attacked 50 of the people in essence he
said if you vote for donald trump
support him in any way you are a fascist
or a semi-fascist whatever semi-fascist
means
and that's i think for someone who's the
head of state who's supposed to be
someone that can unify this country in a
moment of crisis or what have you he
just told half the country you think
they're a danger to the country and that
they're evil
and uh and that that really is
unprecedented people can say whatever
they want about trump and he was pretty
vicious on his political opponents but
well i think you experienced that in the
primaries everyone did
i always laugh about that it's funny
like saying were you mad when he said
this about you and i said well why don't
you ask a guy in a boxing ring if he's
mad that the other guy punched him in
the face i mean they're in a boxing ring
now he punches him in the face at the
airport the next day now you got a
problem
can i and you can say if this is too
personal out of line
i have a stand-up bit about this it's
more so relates to ted cruz because you
know the whole dad involved with jfk
thing was hilarious obviously uh but and
and completely were you surprised i mean
you couldn't have been prepared for the
kind of attacks that they were very aw
they were very off the beaten path was a
part of just going what is happening
well i think it was a very unique
political year and um
but you know what i what i think donald
trump understood instinctively from in
spain 30 years in the limelight of
promoting things is that at the end of
the day even the people that said oh
this is terrible what is he saying they
all covered it like crazy i mean cnn
basically was 24 hours trump right and
during the campaign after the campaign
even now i mean they've dedicated i
don't care if some spaceship lands from
another planet they're going to dedicate
at least a third of their coverage to
donald trump on a daily basis yeah and
so um for me uh he knew how to play that
to get maximum attention and the thing
about ted i always joke with ted about i
said the reason why i know that cubans
were not involved in the murder of jfk
and the assassination is because they
would have told everybody within 48
hours yes
they would not have been able to keep
that a secret they would have told
everybody hey don't say anything but you
know i was on the grassy knoll last week
so um you know that's just uh you know
never they would never never would have
been able to keep that they set up an
unsanctioned boxing match on the grassy
knoll and you're like well okay well
they they make good boxers uh let me
just going back to uh what you're
talking about here he was blaming voters
which i think is is is very key
of course uh joe biden tried to walk it
back now here's something that i didn't
hear a lot of other people talking about
he tried to walk it back saying i meant
maca republicans not mainstream
republicans i've worked with them you
know they've i've worked with them
across the uh zero republicans right
voted with them on the inflation
reduction act does that make you a maga
extremist
yeah i mean
that's the point he gets to decide who
he's talking about and who he isn't i
think what he's basically saying is
anyone who hasn't condemned donald trump
every day for everything
is a manga republican and that's how he
views it but you know the truth to
extremists in american politics or then
at the end of the day the core
conservatism is basically we just want
to go back to normal stuff like let
parents raise their children let them
have some say over what they're being
taught in schools don't teach kids that
their country is inherently evil like
the worst place on the planet because
not only is it not true it's the
complete opposite our history is better
than anybody else and still not perfect
it's better than anybody else's our
military is designed to win wars not
promote social agendas like the proper
use of pronouns rather than focus on the
proper use of pronouns they need to be
focused on how do we blow up you know
chinese naval vessels if they invade
taiwan
um
largely have the states and local
jurisdictions have the amounts of
government power and don't be the only
country in the world where anybody can
just walk across the border and say hey
i'm here illegally and can you please
give me you know a bus ride to the
nearest city that i want to live in and
a cell phone and i promise to show up in
10 years at some court hearing these are
not
radical ideas and the majority of people
support this i also think most people
think like yeah it'd be great if we
could all run cars that are powered by
oxygen that pulled in from the air or
electric batteries that aren't made in
china but we don't have that now and we
ain't going to have that for like 20 or
25 years and so what we don't want to be
is california where they're going to
force everyone to buy electric cars at
the same time as they're telling them
but don't charge your cars because
you're going to create a blockout these
are just common sense things
today is crazy versus normal and that's
really what the division is yes can i
ask you something because you just laid
out a bunch of issues that are obviously
reasonable and many americans agree with
now some people will say that this is
conspiratorial
what i will say is i think there's some
validity to the idea you just touched on
they want you to get electric cars and
then they want to tell you when
you can charge them when you can't right
we've seen people actually charging
teslas with gas generators it's that is
funny
but we also have a party right the
democratic party who wants people in
centrally planned urban areas on public
transit
do you think that that's part of a
design look electric cars because they
know it's not something that can
function they want to remove people who
have autonomous modes of transportation
or is are all these policies do they
just exist sort of in their own separate
bubble because a lot of americans say it
seems like it's part of a plan
well i will tell you this i believe that
the intellectual
center
of everything you're seeing out there is
called marxism and a lot of people that
are cooperating with it don't view it
that way right people think marxism is
socialism socialism is an economic model
that marxism adopts but marxism is about
control and power and it's about saying
we have to control everything we have to
be more powerful than the family more
powerful than religion and church is
more powerful than the media more
powerful than academia more powerful
than the individual the collective is
more important and so you chip away at
anything that rivals your power and i
think that's exactly right if it were up
to these people they will say everyone
should be involved everyone should be in
a car pool
riding a bus or taking a train or riding
a bike to work everybody and and um
that's what everybody should be doing
the reason to save the planet the
reality i think in many ways they enjoy
telling people what to do in their lives
they like to control everything that's
what marxism is always about that's what
it's always been
and that's why i don't think they were
troubled by high gas prices i think they
thought it's going to make it more
expensive for people to drive they're
going to drive less and that's a good
thing and in fact some of them openly
admitted that that's their goal right so
i do think that the underpinning of it
i'm not saying most democrats view
themselves as marxists i'm saying that
many of them do not realize that what is
pushing the agenda that they're driving
is marxism yeah well because one it's
the first generation is control and the
next generation is reliance because they
don't know any better and when you have
a relia
a generation that's reliant upon you for
transportation right it could be for
food take whatever example you want well
it is assumed that it is the
government's job to provide it starts as
control where there's half the country
resisting the next generation
well they're just reliant and of course
you know that very well in cuba and to a
lesser degree you know being raised in
canada i mean you know plenty about uh
prime minister trudeau by the way that
guy does blackface more than any
everyone else combined 12 times it says
i don't know how you get to be leader of
a country but it's a silly place hey i
want to go because i want to talk about
uh the raid and you know right now on
youtube sometimes you're not allowed to
discuss the fbi at all uh depending on
what they declared to be permissible um
so we're going to go to mug club
exclusive but before we do that senator
rubio where's the best place for people
to find you
marco rubio.com i ask them to go on
there learn all about what i've done
what i'm doing what i want to do my
comparisons to the
other people um
being that i'm in the capital i can't
talk about political campaigns per se
but i can tell you that um you know
obviously everybody knows i'm up for
election so i encourage them to go on my
website and i like a lot of what you've
by the way florida is a great petri dish
i think florida really is i'd like to
think texas but the truth is not so much
okay we're going to continue here uh
completely unfettered and i don't think
that senator rubio is going to be all
that different with no filter but i just
don't want to be banned from youtube
because we discussed the raid uh youtube
thank you very much but not really on to
mug club